la crise économique qui se profile à
renforcer cette peur chez les français
du déclassement aux quatre coins du
territoire national cette crise doit
donc être l'occasion de réconcilier nos
territoires avec l'ensemble de restaurer
la confiance de nos concitoyens les uns
envers les autres
la république une et indivisible ne doit
pas demeurer un vain mot
elle doit s'incarner dans les actes que
nous mèneront ensemble collectivement
chacun d'entre nous doit prendre
pleinement conscience de la gravité de
la situation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés
oui oui mes chers collègues nous sommes
à la croisée des chemins soit nous
agissons collégialement pour lutter
efficacement contre les fragilités
économique et la situation sociale
délicate les difficultés rencontrées par
nos citoyens soient soit nous sombrons
dans le pessimisme mortifère l'invectivé
permanente le culte de la division et
l'opposition
sachant donc être les dignes des
exigences légitimes des français qui
attendent de nous élus de la nation un
esprit de concorde de construction
commune en faveur du seul intérêt quand
celui de notre pays
pour ce faire devons faire preuve
d'humilité rappeler ce qui a été réalisé
depuis le début de la crise mais
également faire le point sur nos actions
sans craindre le jugement hâtif ou
partielle de ceux qui pensent pouvoir
faire mieux
davantage tout le temps et dans tous les
domaines laissons-leur leurs certitudes
tâchons d'emprunter pour notre part le
chemin de la co construction
c'est au niveau de nos territoires et
vous allez citer ici territoire le
président larcher dit souvent que nous
représentons les territoires sur ta vous
reprochent aujourd'hui de faire trop
appel aux territoires
quand on parle aux territoires on parle
pas seulement au parlement ce point
ministre on parle aux français qui
chaque jour des difficultés quotidiennes
que vous avez évoquées dans leur travail
dans leur santé dans leurs déplacements
cessons ces réponses concrètes que j'ai
entendu aujourd'hui sachez que moi je ne
crois pas à lier forme et et des
politiques publiques sortes de maladies
qui a frappé notre pays tout au long de
son histoire récente
c'est par une approche monolithique des
difficultés rencontrées comme des
solutions en veille envisager que nous
avons été dans l'incapacité de penser un
modèle d'inclusion qui puisse satisfaire
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens de brest à
strasbourg du havre à prades à ce titre
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
exprimé votre soutien au droit à la
différenciation
que vous souhaiteriez voir consacrer
dans une loi organique farouche partisan
de la décentralisation je suis persuadé
que nous devons entamer une nouvelle
étape de celle ci la reprise économique
et la lutte contre les inégalités
sociales ne pourront être permise que si
les territoires en deviennent des
acteurs centraux
vous avez fixé un cap tracé un chemin la
gestion à court terme des crises ou
d'autres urgences ne peut être l'apanage
d'une politique se veut ambitieuse notre
politique doit s'inscrire dans un temps
long celui de la réflexion de
l'anticipation et de l'action comme l'a
rappelé emmanuel macron à l'occasion de
ces son intervention télévisée
nous devons définir une perspective
engager des réformes nécessaires à la
survie notre système dans la
concertation
l'écouté et le respect du travail en
commun
[Musique]